it's improving the security situation
was a very challenging we had Boko Haram
controlling some territory in not east
part of the country and there was a
clear danger that people induces
lobbyists oferta but many of them have
been deeply moved away from many
villages in the north I said today I
mean it would have lost a lot of
territory you talked about establishing
a joint task force yet many of your
neighbors have complained that they're
not allowed to come over the border to
deal with Boko Haram no but that's
that's what's happening now the Joint
Task Force has come back on stream it's
always been there it was set up
basically to fight I'm banditry across
the Nigerian and Chad and Nigerian
borders but now we've had new levels of
cooperation because it's becoming
obvious to everybody that Boko Haram is
a transnational problem because the Chad
forces who said that they were they
stopped because they didn't have
permission to pursue people from Boko
Haram coming into their country well the
rules of engagement with the generation
attack for sister love for hot pursuit
into across the across the borders until
you meet the other troops across the
body but it is very important obviously
for both sides by the opposition and the
government side to show that you can
control your country within your own
borders oh definitely it's important to
everybody and part of what we know is
that them of course politics kind of
trumps issues politics makes it possible
for people at various times to tend to
paint issues differently but beyond
politics I believed as a consensus in
Nigeria that is an issue that needs to
be dealt with there has been obviously
very serious incidents including
kidnappings and suicide bombing since
the school girls were taken but what is
the status working he tell us about
those school none that were getting
behind the lines of Boko Haram now we're
getting behind the alliance now that
we're getting them out of territories
I'm moving deeper in were hoping to find
clues and we're hoping to find answers
to words in my room the vast bulk of
them are still missing and suggestion
that they've been traffic that's a
possibility but we're going to know more
by the time
get behind their lines so in that sense
Boko Haram can still operate fairly
freely and still kidnap people can still
keep them hostage well the cost a terror
organization because they are suicide
operations are the likely will have
sleeper cells they would likely will
have soft target attacks it were not
only an illusion that displacing them
from territories means an end to Boko
Haram but it means that they do not have
a base to launch the kind of attacks
that they didn't luncheon before but
we're also very hopeful that with the
kite level of equipment intelligence we
have today will be able to degrade their
capacity to operate in major why should
people reelect Goodluck Jonathan because
he's a Democrat by instinct he has
deepened democracy in Nigeria mr. [ __ ]
is not he's a reformed Democrats and
dealing with a Democrat biasing who
started off as a deputy governor a
governor vice president president he
comes to office with clear credentials
of a Democrat and secondly in deepening
democracy in Nigeria he has also made it
possible for people to understand that
our institutions have come to stay
institutions are growing we don't need
the African beeping and then aspiring
elections not necessarily a sign
military Democrat is it no the
postponement of the election has nothing
to do with it doesn't affair with
integrity of the election it does
interfere with democracy because kiloton
has been known president gelatin has
been known to have conducted some of the
best elections in Nigeria because the
suggestion is also being made that
Nigeria did not take advantage of the
period of a higher price and that's
therefore less the economy very exposed
and that's why your currency has
devalued quite dramatically recently
yeah that's a clear and present danger
of democracy is difficult in the
democratic government at the times of
high commodity prices to make
fundamental changes the tendency for
people to say this is our country this
is our natural resource but we do fall
in oil prices I believe the president
has a great opportunity for elected to
diversify the Nigerian economy more to
handle more issues of you have any
questions why hasn't done magic
has been in power when there's been a
higher price yeah he tried it he said I
bullied evaluate with the removal of the
subsidy in 2011 which was in 2012 which
was a major issue and which simplex now
generating dates EJ he's got good
democratic credentials so that means if
he were to be defeated in this election
he would accept that oh yes I'm like I
my point is that this election is he has
no incentive either way he's a winner if
he wins the election he's the president
for the second term if he loses the
election on hands over peacefully he's
an African states man he's he's a true
Democrat the world will need him to
mediate in African countries so this
election in all ramification is a
success story for him I'd away and I
think he has every incentive to make
sure he conducts the free and fair
election mr. can thank you very much
today thank you